un système de retraite aussi subtile
soit-il ne peut fonctionner que s'il
reste suffisamment de français à
travailler et que ce soit par points ou
par répartition il faut que les français
en travaillant génère une masse
colossale argent privé de trop nombreux
prélèvements obligatoires génère alors
une énorme masse d'argent public
en clair dans l'état actuel du pays
aucun système ne peut rassurer les
français car pas de travail pas d'argent
pas de retraite sécurisé et j'y
ajouterai l'obligation monsieur le
premier ministre d'une gestion ultra
vertueuse de l'argent public
aucun système de retraites ne résistera
à la disparition du travail de
production et de fabrication d'europe
tous ceux qui travaillent n'en peuvent
plus de la multitude de normes édictées
alors que le communautarisme et
l'intégrisme fracture notre pays
nous sommes inquiets pour notre idéal
républicain à quelques mois des
élections municipales il faut défendre
notre république contre l'entrisme que
pourraient pratiquer les candidats
radicaliser dangereux dans les conseils
municipaux
le gouvernement a renoncé à combattre
sur le terrain du droit le
communautarisme aux élections locales
mais rien n'empêche pourtant d'agir
contre sa dérive la plus radicale le
clivage qui se joue désormais est celui
qui oppose les vrais républicains à ce
qu'ils baissent la tête et fait elle
toujours de ne rien voir
laisserez-vous le suffrage universel
confier une part de la souveraineté
nationale à des ennemis de la république
ou bien soutiendrez-vous notre
proposition de loi en surfant ainsi sur
la transition écologique vous souhaitez
imposé un dispositif de consignes pour
recyclage des bouteilles en plastique
je crois qu'il faut cesser madame la
ministre le concours lépine des fausses
bonnes mesures mises en oeuvre en
matière de développement durable qu'ils
ne servent en rien l'environnement tout
en augmentant les coûts pour les
collectivités donc pour les
contribuables
vous le savez les hôpitaux publics sont
au bord du gouffre le mal n'est pas
nouveau ils datent d'il ya au moins une
vingtaine d'années vos annonces récentes
ne seront pas en mesure de résoudre la
crise qui éclate aujourd'hui ce chaos de
l'hôpital public a aussi été nourrie par
les carences de prise en charge de la
médecine de ville manque de formation de
nouveaux médecins généralistes mauvaise
répartition sur le territoire national
aujourd'hui trouver un médecin
généraliste
lorsque le vôtre vient de cesser son
activité
lorsque l'on des ménages devient une
mission quasi impossible
[Musique]